- Hi, everybody and welcome.
Thank you for joining us.
I'm Stephen Pitti, Professor
of History, American Studies,
and Ethnicity Race Migration here at Yale
and Director of Yale Center
for the Study of Race,
Indigeneity, and Transnational Migration.
I'm delighted today to host this event
with three terrific artists
who've been fellows,
this semester at Yale's RITM Center.
They were selected from an amazing
international pool of applicants,
and we've been thrilled in recent months
to play a small role in helping
them to advance their work.
We're grateful for the ways
in which they've contributed
to our campus community over time
and excited about what lies ahead.
So we expect this event will run
a little bit more than an hour.
I'll introduce our three artists briefly,
and then each of them
will share their work
for roughly 10 or 15 minutes.
Fellows, I'll send you a direct
message at minute 15 or so
just to remind you to wrap up.
So please keep your eye on the messages.
And afterwards, after
they've finished talking,
I'll invite the artists
to talk with one another
if they'd like to do that.
And maybe I'll have a
question or two for them,
but we're also hoping that
members of the audience
will send in questions
via the Q&A function.
So if you send a comment or
a question there in the Q&A,
I'll do my best to then
share it with the panelists
towards the end of our time together.
I wanna thank our center
staff, Nicole Edwards,
Maggie Katz, and Victoria Stone-Cadena
for their hard work in
running this Fellows Program
and so much else and for
making this event happen today.
Let me now introduce Sonia,
and Rodney, and akua quickly,
and then I'll get out of the way.
Sonia E. Barrett performs
composites of plants,
animals, elements and people
to create interventions
that presence their objectification
and commodification,
she also thinks about
how to change perceptions
of phenomena in nature that are a given.
The work seeks to create new questions
where there was a kind of certainty
that has to do with the hegemony
of normative wester European values.
Her work unpacks the boundaries
between the determined and the determining
with a focus on race and gender.
She makes sculptural works
so she can run her
hands along the fissures
and manifest strategies for multiple
compatible existences and mourn.
Her sculptural practice
includes placemaking
with a view to assembling communities
under the threat of
climate to reclaim space
as well as instituting permanently.
Sonia is a MacDowell fellow
and has been recognized
by the Premio Ora prize,
New York Art-Slant showcase for sculpture
and the Neo Art Prize.
She has exhibited by the
National Gallery of Jamaica,
32 degrees East Gallery, Kampala, Uganda,
the Heinrich Böll Institute
Germany, the British Library,
the Museum of Derby, and
the Kunsthaus Nürnberg.
Her work has been shown
at a number of galleries
including the OCCCA
California, the NGBK Berlin,
Tete Berlin, The Format
Contemporary in Milan and Basel
and the Rosenwald Wolf
Gallery, Philadelphia.
Her works have been published
in the International Review
of African American Art,
Black History 365 Journal,
Kunstforum International,
Protocollum, ELSE Journal and
the Contemporary and Platform,
and British Art Studies Journal.
She is a co-initiator
of the AIPCC in Bavaria.
Thank you Sonia.
Rodney Gomez is a poet and urbanist
whose work explores the
intersection of place,
culture, and history in the
South Texas Borderlands.
Rodney has a particular
interest in Latinx poetry,
art phrases, and visual poetry.
His collections include
"Arsenal With Praise Song",
recipient of the Helen
C. Smith Memorial Award
for best poetry book from the
Texas Institute of Letters.
"Geographic Tongue",
winner of the Pleiades
Press Visual Poetry Series.
"Ceremony of Sand" winner of
the Writers' League of Texas
and Discovery Prize, and
"Citizens of the Mausoleum"
finalist for the John A. Robertson Award.
His work appears in
Poetry, New England Review,
The Gettysburg Review,
Denver Quarterly, Rattle,
North American Review,
Verse Daily, Poetry Daily,
and other journals.
His chapbook, "Mouth
Filled Night" was awarded
the Drinking Gourd Prize
from Northwestern University's Poetry
and Poetics Colloquium.
He's the recipient of the Editor's Prize
from the Rhino Magazine, the
Gloria Anzaldúa Poetry Prize,
the Rania Royal Prize, and
the Orison Anthology Award.
A member of the Macondo Writers' Workshop.
Gomez was the 2020, 2021 poet
Laureate of McAllen, Texas,
and received an Academy of
American Poets Fellowship.
He serves as advisory
editor for FlowerSong Press,
and a board member of Newfound,
a nonprofit publisher
that explores how place
shapes identity, imagination,
and understanding.
He works as executive director
of parking and transportation
at the University of
Texas Rio Grande Valley,
and is a certified planner,
transportation planner,
and project manager.
Thank you for being here Rodney.
akua naru is a hip hop artist,
poet, producer, lecturer, and activist.
Who's been called "Toni
Morrison of hip hop."
Her body of work like Morrisons
always holds black folk at its center.
A sonic love letter
sprawled across four albums
and countless features.
She released her debut album,
"The Journey aflame" followed
by a live version in 2012,
"live & aflame sessions."
naru followed up this
release with two more albums,
"The Miners Canary," 2015
and "The Blackest Joy," 2018.
She's performed hundreds of
shows in more than 50 countries
across five continents
with her 6-piece band.
She's recorded with Tony Allen,
Eric Benét, Angelique Kidjo,
Tuneyards, Questlove,
Georgia Anne Muldrow,
Christian Scott, Rah
Digga, Mulatu Astatke,
Bernard Purdie, sorry,
Cody ChesnuTT, and more.
She's a has a series of
ongoing collaborations
with Canadian filmmaker and
photographer Gregory Colbert.
In 2021, she voiced the
"Save the Night" commercial
for German company, Jägermeister.
Towards a larger vision of empowerment,
she's hosted workshops,
healing circles, lectures,
and participated on
panels that explore topics
such as African Spiritualties
in relation to hip hop
and sexism in the hip hop industry.
She's lectured at many, many universities
around the world and has been a fellow
at both Harvard and Brown Universities.
She is also the founder and
artistic director of The Keeper,
the first comprehensive archive
focusing on women's contributions
to five decades of hip
hop music and culture.
So with that, I thank you for
being here all three of you.
And I'm gonna turn this over,
I think to Sonia, Sonia.
- Hello, thank you for introduction.
It's just wonderful to be
here and in the company of
such amazing artists as well.
I'm just going to share my screen.
So I'm just going touch on
just about three things.
Firstly, I hope everyone can
see that's the screen, great.
The premise of my work,
just one large or two large
installations I've done.
And then one work that's in progress
since I've been at Yale.
So to just really start with this,
my work is really all about
inter-species object objectification.
So I'm really thinking
about how it's a given that
our everyday existence
is like predicated on
the depletion of animal
and mineral life on earth,
but also that there are groups of laborers
who are unrecognized unenumerated,
and are essential to the status quo,
they're really holding
everything up so to speak.
And in those terms I'm thinking about
the history of migration,
black and brown peoples,
caregivers, historical slavery,
descendants, historical
descendants of historical slaves,
and also modern day slavery.
This is like really the premise of my work
and modern day slavery often comes up
with a lot of resistance
and just some figures here
about modern day slavery.
It's that it's a real phenomena.
The next thing I'd like to share is the,
so basically the modern
day slavery is really it's,
it's a very intimate space.
Modern day slaves handle all
the food we put in our mouths,
while the laboring in
the farming industry,
they highlight Italian
in the sex industry.
They deal with our bodily
fluid, blood, fluid, mucus
in caregiving roles.
It's a very intimate content
that's often overlooked.
So for me to really think
about the objectification
of black and brown people
and people as furniture.
And if you think about the
chair you are sitting on now,
it's right into the contact,
it's holding your entire weight.
But you probably didn't even
see it when you sat down.
There's a history of looking at furniture
in art and it's not...
Many people have looked
at furniture and art
and looking at the
history of furniture art,
I discovered there's some art,
some furniture has already
got like a live element,
it's got a line foot in it.
This is the queen and
style it's been revived
the most times in Europe.
It's the most revived
style of you in furniture.
And in my practice,
I started replacing that
furniture with my own body.
And discovered that I
didn't actually need a prop,
my body looked already looked
like that kind of line foot.
So in making that foot,
I could begin to think about
objectification of my own body.
This was a surreal work I
made a response to Fanon,
his quote where he speaks about how
we have to stop our beauty
slumber in the first world
and wake up from a beauty
and respond to the needs of
those in the third world.
And so this is, being the
bed and getting in the bed.
I sort off the leg of the
bed and put my arm there
so that I was the bed and
tried to get into the bed
to try and problematize
this idea of splity slumber
oppression and define
this kind of brown space
of being in between those
two so called worlds.
I work with furniture and
I keep thinking about it
again and again, the work that
I'm doing is to corpse pop.
So to expand what part is for
living, what's worth mourning.
These are American table
legs, 18th century.
I'm also trying to think
about how can we mourn
maybe an ore as well as a brown body,
as well as a tree and a
plant, everything together
and perhaps this is one body
and that we shouldn't think
about them as separate things.
I'm thinking about
violation and the witnessing
the violation as a continuum,
as a holding space,
Kevin Bales talks about how
slave holding, not slave owning.
I'm asking you to be
detective and think about who,
what the crime is, bloodless crime scene.
This is a gentleman's
smoking chair from a club,
and also trying to strategize,
how can we move from objectification?
And this is one way in that
we can rest at the space
of oppression rather than leaving.
So this resting, this
chair articulated itself,
we wanted to rest.
Also, we can collectivize,
in collectivizing even if
we hold the same viewpoint,
we can disrupt this space of consumption.
So it used to seat 12
and now nobody can sit at
this chair at this table.
And it also illustrates the problem
in that there's a kind
of holding space as well.
And it's like looking into
the bowels of maybe a ship
or a holding space.
I have so much heartache
and headache with this work.
The most like a key
headache happened after
I'd done my last research in New Orleans.
And I finished being at a plantation
and there was actually
headache tablets in the museum.
And I felt, oh my God, I can't
wait to leave this space.
I can't wait to go back to London to deal,
just to get out of this plantation space.
And then I realized that's
actually crazy because
London is really an
epicenter of all of this.
So geography, isn't the next
thing I started to tackle
because London is seen as
separate from New Orleans,
it's seen separate from
the Caribbean or Africa.
And so I started to braid those spaces.
So those maps from those
spaces of triangle spade.
So this is London Corn Road,
that's the river Thames here.
This is New Orleans
focusing on Congress Square,
dreadlocked with all those other places.
And again, this is map of Jamaica.
And then something happened in (mumbles)
and trying to smash these spaces together
and belie the map.
The map left the page,
and this became an
installation that I did at the,
in the Royal Geographic Society in London.
And so this is in the map room,
and this is actually an
intellectual critique
of map making in many ways,
but I haven't got time to
talk about that right now.
It started to intervene with the images,
the artwork, existing
artwork in the map room.
This is a picture of Captain
Cook with his captain's log.
So it's reframed him
with his hand on his log.
I shredded archival maps
from the colonial office
to make this work.
It happened in lockdown,
I started a map collective
as a collecting of
map making women to work on this together
and together we claimed a
space into make a new map
and more often almost a more accurate map,
which is full of holes,
which is not concerned with surface.
And similarly creating space
or holding space was this work,
which is sky,
which was commissioned by
the black history month
in Florence it's made of hair.
So the hair creates a new skies.
The hair is loaned, borrowed, bought.
And the idea was because at
that time there were so many
spaces that were on fire.
All the spaces that were on
fire were indigenous spaces
where the Celeste still had
been reconfigured as white.
So in Australia in the content of Africa,
in Latin America, there was places of,
all these places were on fire.
So I was interested in this blackout,
but also in reconfiguring
aspects of blackness
for it to become a space that's malleable,
transformative, soft,
but also how can we be of
many soils authentically?
So the black is pore,
is like the pregnant,
fertile life given cloud,
the water raises in one place
and moves to another
and raises down another.
So this was really a new
idea of how could we,
how can we think of blackness
and new symbol of blackness
it's being soft and
powerful and malleable,
and with many places,
and this work held space for
people to gather under it,
which was kind of place making.
It was also response
to this mahogany floor,
which is so much death for me.
The last thing I want to
share with you is this,
this new series which happened
while I was commissioned by Britain
to write an article on Hogarth.
Hogarth does a lot of
furniture performances.
This is one of his whereby this pair is
they're both unfaithful.
And so this chair on its
back is kind of echoing the,
the sexual exploits of
this unfaithful pair,
but he himself depicted
himself in a chair.
And on my commentary in
the Tete I noticed that,
this is a mahogany chair,
which means that it's actually
grown in the Caribbean
and shipped in the same
ships that black and brown
bodies were move used to move people.
This chair, I reconfigured
just subtle reconfigurations.
This is actually in my fellowship,
I was able to purchase an
actual chair from the time.
So you can see, these are very similar
if you look at this chair.
And so they're almost the same.
And so there's just
been a couple of changes
made to this chair to try
and point out the fact,
the woman in the chair,
which was a very controversial
thing to point out.
This is the work that supports it.
Firstly, I removed the pad.
So now this she's standing,
this is figure of the woman for me
and she's standing on a rail, but she was,
she looks more precarious, but
she was always as precarious
'cause the pad was not for her,
it was for servicing
someone else's comfort.
There on the top, there were
these two called scrolls,
but I felt that they were
really actually nipples
and that they were available to anyone
who wanted to move the chair.
So I just took them off here
and put them on the body off the chair.
The chair is not naked.
These are the bits that
would signify that this woman
is in a committed relationship.
And so she's actually fully clothed.
She's actually on a pedestal,
the pedestal was in here.
So a lot of work before I
was trying to close her legs
of these available chairs but
then I realized in this piece,
she's actually, her legs are here.
So there's a thing about
losing legs, finding new legs.
Also she has a scallop which
is ingrained on her chest,
which references another
goddess, like figure,
which is another thing I
can't go into at the moment,
'cause there's no time.
This is another work that
emerged from this series.
And it's, what if
oppression is like a dress
that we could take off, but
this body is still there,
it's not really a dress, so
this is the structure of,
of objectification here.
It's actually a men's trouser, hanger.
And then I was able to
purchase the whole set
and really have a have like explore this
and this last work here,
how to actualize this
chair is the curved chair.
So she's actually able
to reach behind herself
to reach out to another
woman who's flipped herself.
So that this thing that removes them is,
is no longer blocking her
to support the other one.
This woman has actualized herself,
but by borrowing someone else's arms.
So someone else has doesn't have any arms.
This woman's arms are folded.
So all this is a meditation
very much along the lines
of Audrey Lord, Sister Outsider.
How can we help each other
to articulate ourselves and,
and to release ourself from
service and all the parts,
all the sitting parts have gone.
There she is, reaching
out to another person.
And what was left was this devastation,
this landscape of all the stumps,
which really reminded me
of the kind of prayering
that happened in the forest,
where these mahogany trees were actually
cleared the first time
to even make the chairs
where the people were
moved in the same ships.
So this is this mashing
of race in environment.
And my final piece that
I'm sharing is this,
this is just the back of the same chair.
Removing the plane, so in a
time when we're thinking about
de-platforming white men on statues,
what would it mean for us to leave?
There are platforms or to
the platform that we are on,
where would we go?
So basically just thanks,
that's the whole presentation,
thanks to all these people
who have supported my work,
especially this iteration,
which has been more
expansive than I've been,
ever been able to do before.
And yes, and those are
my photography credits.
Thank you.
- Amazing. Thank you so much, Sonia.
Thank you. Thank you.
And Rodney, I'm gonna turn it over to you.
- Thank you, Stephen.
That was amazing.
Sonia, I'm so honored to be a fellow
along with these wonderful,
wonderful artists.
My fellowship project has been focused on
creating a new poetry collection
using traditional creation
of traditional poems,
as well as visual poems,
lyric essays and the like.
And I've really been thinking
lately a lot about historical
violence along the US, Texas Borderlands
and how that specifically
violence directed against Mexicans
and Mexican Americans, how
that has sort of shaped
a lot of our built environment.
As Stephen mentioned,
I'm an urban planner.
And so I think a lot
about how urban spaces,
how the built environment is,
is structured and shaped
by historical forces
and by different mechanisms of power.
And so I've been thinking
a lot about violence
in you know historically how has that
resulted in the way that we move?
And we live inside these
spaces that we call cities
and also rural spaces as well,
especially along the border.
I was particularly interested in this,
this historical episode called La Matanza,
which was basically a period
of state sanction violence
in the late 1800s, early
1900s against Mexicans,
and Mexican Americans,
the Texas State Rangers,
for instance, carried on this
long campaign of murdering,
Mexicans that they either
charged with fictitious crimes
or simply killed out of
spite or out of hate.
And it tore families apart,
really did a lot to
undermine the influence
and the power of Mexicans who
had established themselves
in the lower Rio Grande Valley
and other places along the border.
So I've been thinking about that and then
thinking also about the
fact of migration as well
and how we as a nation treat
those who are either refugees
or migrants moving across
the border to the US
from other places, whether it's Mexico
or Latin America or wherever.
And so I've been sort
of reading on that a lot
and I've been creating
these different poems
that sort of take that as all of that as,
all of that as background
to inform the poems.
Of course, this is in
scholarship, this is poetry
and so what I'll read is not,
or doesn't necessarily
have a connection to,
that's my toddler, doesn't
necessarily have a connection to
real historical episodes or isn't,
it's not journalism or anything like that,
but it is informed by
all of that research.
So I'm gonna read a series of poems
from works in progress
from the manuscript.
In this first one, and I don't
like to preface my poems,
so I'm just gonna read
them, one after the other,
after giving the title.
So this first one is
called "The Desert Cold."
A person by weight could be Mesquite
in its fully flowered state,
whether felt or fastened
de-sapling to steak,
whether they're used
for its limbs easy news,
the body gives its full
freight to the soil
and the soil takes it through gap teeth,
two potato sacks of buffalo head nickels,
half a gun, a pound of salt,
which must have ring the neck
like an earthly hell or
just before a final breath.
Two little body for the
pale of milk inside,
enough to carve a sash of
skin against a spidery bush,
claiming back what it gave
when a nearby star last flared.
A lake of ash, what the sun will do,
connective to soften
and structure an animal
to grieve the animal's absence
as a wreath grieves polished pine.
Nothing or air without
mass, most invisible thrust,
that thing which in the
desert cold is least missed
and by its lack of heft will last to go.
A man is murdered who wanders a bird
where we lose the umbilicus,
encounter animus anatomical
mat, peppered with black lakes,
where our organ should be,
where we pray never to sputter,
run from little (indistinct)
highways or moats or walls.
A man is murdered who wanders a bird
where we learn cheekbones or destiny
designate official boundaries for dying,
bloom the prison population
and imprison populations,
oil into anonymity or
call unwanted attention
to our temperature,
where we receptacle
into bruised buildings,
disowned this or that
synonym for communion,
where we embarrass
ourselves with a nation.
State flags into fields already
claimed and call it density,
where we attribute pestilent,
mark ourselves endangered,
where we are surveilled,
determinist zip codes,
where finches will not eat a single seed
subdivided parcels for
garages and private whaling,
where a cleansing rain
is perpetually postponed,
where the accused after baptism
are accepted for justice,
where the justice is placed
in a vault for later opening,
where the world burns before the opening.
House.
We came into the house and
the house came into us.
It was a Georgian and outside,
there had been a plantation
and later a field
where Mexicans held their
waste until there were sprayed
with pesticides and
swindled out of their wages,
it was a haunted house.
We took it from our ancestors,
we frilled it with freshly
painted gables and columns.
We knocked out walls and
made the interior habitable
by the market standards.
And the standards of trust funds drawn
for the run all like
deer sipping lake water.
We knew murder was laved into the house,
the same as floors, the ceilings
as the quiet mold of the larder.
We knew that if the many voices
buried inside the house got too loud,
we could run annihilate
the shape of another house
and make it our own.
We could do this
indefinitely house to house
fixture by fixture and this is why
we are sent to be fearful of death
because we know we can never leave
a piece of ourselves behind.
House.
A patchwork tin wall,
a poisoned water table,
a house without gates is still a house.
You take another house taken
by the bank and you strip it
as you strip the bark from pine
and you squeeze another house out of it,
the drywall and bathtub
even the suspect fume.
You feel the husk out of its shape.
You clone the Shell's
dearest parts and leave.
A house without tick is still a house,
without granite, a house
that sways and gusts
and leaks of thunderhead.
You sleep bare bone on the floor,
go a house full of mold, still a house.
The house kills anyone who lives there,
it is no different than a
house with so many rooms.
You hope death will never find you.
The heart is a mock metronome.
The average life expectancy of a,
is five years less.
The heart is a mock metronome.
It was the Romans who gave
the name lakuna, to lack,
nights with missing moons,
a cleft in memory, scarcity
of affordable housing.
The difference between visiting Mars
and taking out a loan to pay for kidneys.
The power and how a
fist held up to the sky
can blot out a circling vulture.
The same hand, if held out
for alms in a glass office
is considered assault.
The average wealth of
a, is purely rhetorical.
The kind of wound that forecloses suture.
Fireworks engulf little crimes.
To toddlers, a lemon is a
room small enough to be held.
The average waiting time for a new heart
in a public hospital is three years.
This is a lie, there are no
secondhand hearts without crime.
The actual waiting time for
a new lung is disharmony.
Advice, eat right, exercise.
Try not to worry over a lack of agency,
a valued meals and socialment.
what transmogrofies pews a
candle lit by a saints (mumbles).
A broken tambourine its symbols
infused with the leftover
zeal of a more gullible generation.
The average years is
incarcerated is identical
to the number of years it takes to build
a two-story house with a gable.
A gardens capillary sprinklers,
a backyard grove filled
with bright yellow lemons.
Colonial paneling.
I think of a thumbprint
permanently impressed
on a threshold's neck.
The number of invisible
hands used to coax ornament
out of pine.
In a house full of beveled doors asked
who designed the doors
and who awakened the wood?
Only a butcher nose, if
bones had a good body.
Who ate in this room?
Who was allowed to sit and
who stood at the window?
Every nail in the kitchen had a driver,
every blow of the hammer was a rain jack,
who welded the lock afraid my presence
could deconstruct the frame.
Polarized brick I could never afford
into its constituent weak forces.
The bathtub is innocent.
The real drowning was done in the deed.
And I think I would read one more.
We become animals or grow out of them.
On a trail, a coyote is
used to smuggle migrants.
We found a mesquite tree and underwear
hanging like crumpled
maps on its sharp branches
because we knew who had
put it there and why.
A wire of fear shook through our joints.
After some time my friend
who now has a daughter said,
"I wonder how many other things
we could hang from this tree."
Thank you.
- [Stephen] Thank you
so much Rodney, akua.
- Yes, yes.
So first I wanna start by saying like,
what I try to do like,
for me language is the
most important thing.
I'm always looking at ways to language
in ways that further my calls,
what can I do with language?
How can I
write in a way that
expands the possibilities
for language within the hip hop context?
Because when you listen to rap lyrics,
or when we think of hip hop I mean,
I think so many of us have
been so miseducated, right?
There's this is a science,
this is for us to sit and,
cast this forth, right?
You're thinking about meter, it's metric,
there's rhyme scheme, there's
poetic device that the,
that the artist employs
alliteration for assonance.
You have to do all of that,
I mean, you create these
rules for yourself,
depending on your style as a writer.
And you have to obviously abide by them
and tell a story at the same time.
It's not easy, it's not easy.
So when you hear people like Nas,
who you know is a absolutely
brilliant storyteller,
if you listen to hip hop or black thought
from the roots for example,
who's a brilliant storyteller.
Or if you listen to a woman
artist from lovely New Haven,
in Connecticut called
the called akua naru,
she's a brilliant storyteller
so they say as well.
I'm interested in trying
to tell the perfect story.
I'm not sure if it's possible,
but I want to tell that story
in the midst of all these other things
that you have to obey,
if you call it hip hop.
So once upon a time I wrote
this story and I'm gonna try to,
pay attention to the time
and get through this.
I would normally put a beat
on for y'all and just rock,
just to say that I did it over Zoom
and just hit y'all with
the real concert, so ill,
but that's not gonna
work because the time,
it might be a lag and also,
I want you to really hear the words.
Like, if you forget everything,
please remember the words,
'cause I thought it was
important enough to write it.
So in the chorus, I say
it came through sweat,
but we made it we're here.
The chorus is sung in Uganda three verses.
I'm gonna try to do it quick.
So stick with me so that you can hear me.
So I can then say this,
all this other stuff.
But I say, I said this in
the first verse, I said,
and I'm gonna just pull this out
just to give you an impression.
Now in the dark when the night's wild,
you could hear her cry,
couldn't pee inside.
She round back near the outhouse.
Dignified tears strength in her pride,
fuck what they talking about.
Skin like Jesus feet burning
the fire hero woo cloud.
She bake a meat pie, sweet
potato, wild polished silverware
stitched to him or miss (mumbles).
Keep the sheets white high
heat over a beach child
on her feet for hours,
breastfeed the baby's sleep now.
She keep her head bow trained
to lower her gay smile,
when called though was
never her name child.
Granddaughter other slave made
since the days of the big house,
flat hand under the servant
tray now when they sit down.
Retreat to the corner, she
ground becomes smaller.
Watch from the world of
invisible men and shrink more.
Learn to disappear behind,
yes man's and blank stairs.
Hear negros falling from thin
lips landing intense ear.
It came through sweat but
we made it we're here.
When she alone she say her name
just to hear it called, answer
herself in third person,
rock letter Mos.
Miss Hatty made hines with a why
from a long line of root workers.
Lord, mother of four,
they across town with their uncle Roy.
Can't visit but twice a month,
when she leave him the
way the baby boy cried
till he passed out dash
to block the front door,
grab her apron and try to
hold on for just a moment,
more plea for place in their arms.
Mama got a sweet floors.
She hear her heartbreak loudest
and screams down the corridor,
shuts glass cut deep point
like a repeated porus y'all.
When the bills do was never enough,
she keep with Phyllis lost a
ring on the floor up y'all.
Sent her daughter appointed that morning,
head to school up north,
organized a search party though
it never turned up.
Low bubble shoes lost same
size as Hatty middle boy
kicks always a few eggs
short of a certain moist.
It came through sweat,
but we made it we're here.
She smiled, but she don't mean it.
Master of all secrets, all
CNI from the blind spot
is their weakness.
Know how to grind glass make
it passed off as season.
Rumors of witchcraft she
laughed with all teethed in.
Herbs for every task,
for murder to high fever
who heard it when she grabbed
and raped her that evening,
he strangled till she shake fingers,
breaking haled breathing
wave from the staircase,
same hand stroke fill
his face while sleeping.
She says she cleaned these
crackers porch Thursdays
quarter to four, kids know to walk by,
but never wave nigh from the yard.
Make sure they close
neat pants, press woo,
please spray star that hard please.
Skin half sweat has aline.
Over here Ms. Brag to her people laughed,
so she cries say her made
loyal and meet trustworthy
for a Negro colored girl, why last may,
when her husband died sudden
out the blue what's her name
consulted through the time,
it came through sweats,
but we made it we're here.
For me, as I said, like, I'm
interested in telling stories.
I wanna tell the perfect story.
I'm not sure if it's
possible, but you know,
like 50 Cents said, "He's gonna
get rich while die trying."
And I'm gonna just die trying
to tell that perfect story.
So from like at this point, right?
Like I've been touring and
producing, performing globally,
like archiving and as I
think about my artistry,
for me I'm interested in
language, text, and how texts
can be placed in conversation with music
and movement and choreograph dance and,
and attached to bodies and
how those bodies could help
assist in the animation of my story.
And so that's what kind
of led me to theater.
And so, but before I go
into that, I wanna say that.
So Dr. Trisha Rose published a book called
"Longing to Tell" in 2003.
And this was for me at the time,
the first time that I had
read a compilation of,
of black women's interior lives.
So it was an oral history.
She spoke to women across the country,
black women and told these stories.
And it was, I think, what
21 women, three chapters,
through the fire guarded
heart and something left,
always something left to love.
You have to keep in mind that
this is before social media,
before the hashtag like black women magic,
before me too and times
up, I mean, it was risky.
And I was so struck by these stories that,
talked about black women's lives,
trauma and loss, but also
resilience and power, joy,
motherhood, friendship, of
course, sex, sexuality, trauma.
It was very heavy
and at some point I got lucky
enough to meet Trisha Rose
and we actually became friends.
And I had always said to her, like,
"I understand, you know,
black noise is popping."
I mean, it was an amazing read.
It's done wonderful thing for the field.
But "Longing to Tell" was that
was the one that really spoke to me.
And then, as I'm thinking about
ways to expand as an artist
and as I said, like language, movement,
dance and all those things, I
thought, why not adapt this?
And so right now I'm working on a project
which I call a ghetto libretto, right?
Ghetto for the ways in which,
for our original sort of
understanding of the word as
for a confined place for outsiders,
a libretto, musical theater.
So it's text, it's rap
lyrics, it's poetry,
but I couldn't just say a
play and I was working on,
and this is still sort of
like a working concept,
but I needed a way to language it so that,
I wasn't saying a play
and then I had to give you
this whole long spiel,
so you could understand
what the thing really is.
And so right now, like I'm
working on, a stage adaptation,
just so this is like, it's
divided obviously into three X,
just like the book is three chapters.
I basically distilled
the 21 women in her book
into six characters.
And these stories illustrate
themes of love and laws,
betrayal, commitment, parent-child bonds,
domestic violence, sexual
abuse, racial terror,
sexual identity, pleasure,
addiction, community, friendship,
childbirth, death, love,
and of course, for me,
I'm not really interested in just a mirror
retelling of these stories,
but I'm also interested in magic.
So because I, I don't wanna,
retraumatize my audience.
So it's like you come in
and there's something else,
for example, there's a moment in which,
there's a baby that strangled to death,
but actually the baby has agency.
And so the baby then chooses
to die and the baby can now
manipulate circumstances
in the real world.
So that way there's like a
buffer and you don't just leave,
you know, shook.
And so it's kind of like,
I want you to think about,
it's kind of like for
color girls meats, hold on.
'Cause I wrote it out.
'Cause I thought about it today
and I thought it was hilarious.
Lemme see what y'all
got (mumbles) hold on.
It was like when,
if the colored girls meets
Jasmine Sullivans hotels,
meets the black holiness
church meets a Greek chorus.
Plus a little (mumbles) twist,
you know, in 2022 and 2023.
So I guess I'll keep it at that
so that I don't go over time.
- Thank you so much akua.
Wow. I mean, this has been incredible
listening to all of you, all three of you.
And of course, I didn't know
what you were gonna say,
what you exactly what you
were gonna talk about,
but I did wanna take the chance to try
to start engaging a
conversation and asking you
if you're interested in
engaging one another.
So as you were thinking, I was
trying to think of ways to,
to prompt conversation and
facilitate conversation here.
And there are probably ways
that I'm not imagining that you
all the three of you may
be thinking about already,
but I have a few in mind and one of them
was just to see if anybody
wanted to think together about,
about the idea of being a storyteller
and the way that akua talked about it.
But also Sonia, you kind
of referenced the detective
in your work and Rodney,
I'm not sure how you would think about
a kind of figurative character
or argento figure of the sort
like a storyteller or a detective.
I'm not sure I heard anything similar
in what you were saying,
but maybe just to,
to kind of throw back at you
a reminder of what Sonia was
saying about the detective.
I think you talked about
a detective of the,
of the bloodless crime scene.
So I'm not I quite, if
I got that correctly
and akua talked about your interest in
telling the perfect story and seeing that
as sort of a part of the
mandate or the charge
that you have.
So let me just put that out
there for the three of you
and see if any of you
wanna take any of that up.
Having listened to one another.
- I'm happy to jump in.
I think, it's so interesting
that the stories, I mean,
of course with Rodney and
like poetry is like always
exploding, like multiple
meanings of spaces.
And I mean, in a case of rap,
there's so much exposed
in of meaning as well.
So I think it's really interesting,
this kind of vibration
these vibrating spaces
that are resonant with multiple meanings.
As far as storytelling, I mean,
I went to literary fiction
because it seemed to be like the,
a really interesting lens
to look at all the bodies
in my work,
because literally the crime
genre really happened after
really exploded in
Britain after world war,
after the world war.
And it became very
popular to think about to,
and the reason was because
there were so many bodies
after the war and so many...
It wasn't clear who had
committed the crime exactly.
And we didn't know where
all these people were,
we just knew they were
missing and actually gone.
So it was really, really
cathartic for people to like do a,
to read crime fiction,
'cause at the beginning,
there's this unknown body,
there are these unknown,
we don't know who did it,
we don't know who's dead,
we don't know how it happened,
but by the end of the story,
we know all those things.
So in this bloodless crime
scene that I'm making,
I feel like I'm asking you to kind of like
have a hunch about who done it
and also providing the body for catharsis.
Like a lack of a body is like
a lack of a grievable body,
which is what the state
of the DSPO is right now.
It's like it's
psychologically problematic.
So I'm providing those
bodies and I'm putting them
in the homes of multi-generational wealth.
Well, no one will let me do that.
But those furniture
comes from those spaces.
And intervening in them, and I think,
it's also kind of trickster in
that you are trying to refuse
the binary in a discourse.
So like Chris Davian,
so you don't have to
just like go to Roger,
you also have a hunch that you follow
and to work out which way to go.
So in many ways that's the kind of story
that I'm interested in
that, that literary lens.
And rather than, I mean, I'm
curious also to something about
how she didn't, she doesn't
want to retraumatize,
she said, and I agree,
"I don't wanna retraumatize my people."
And this is something that I
really felt very sensitive to
and also stopped my making at one point
when I was just worried
all these bodies, like,
am I just retraumatizing?
But no, I'm trying to get to another space
of like catharsis,
the kind of catharsis that you
have after, you've read that.
For me perfect story was
that you've done it like,
when you have everything
resolved at the end.
Yeah. So...
- Can I just say that as you were talking,
I'm also reminded that some
of the best detective stories,
the best crime fiction
and actually also raises
questions about what
the crime is after all.
One thinks that they
know what the crime was,
but the best in the genre
actually exposes crimes
that are far deeper and far bigger
than might be revealed on the first pages.
And I mean, to me, Sonia,
your work also does that
at least for me, it raises,
it forces questions and
raises deeper analysis
than one might think that they're going
to be involved in right away.
- That's so interesting because
I noted down from Rodney,
he said, the bathtub is innocent,
the real drowning is done in the deed.
And so there is another
kind of crime space,
right there where I think that's,
like the murder and the
bathtub is the classic,
is the classic crime scene, right?
And I don't know if you
want talk to that Rodney,
but I really like that one line where,
where the drowning is an deed,
which I really feel is
something I'm trying to get to,
like, I'm looking at
the things in the house
and the house itself is a problem,
but the things and so I don't know
if Rodney wants to talk to that.
- Yeah and Rodney, I was also struck,
I was struck very much by that line,
"Only a butcher knows if
bones had a good body."
And then in some ways perhaps again,
reminding me of Sonia a
little bit, that we know,
I think you said "We knew
murder was laid into the house."
So all of these seem to be
kind of like, I don't know,
things that occur to me in the
same way they did to Sonia.
But I wanna throw this open also to a coop
because you're, you're
also up if you want be.
- I didn't know if akua
was gonna say something,
your sound is off.
- No I was waiting for you.
Please.
- Yeah.
Okay, I'll go then.
Yeah, I'm not...
I mean, I guess one of
the primary concerns in,
in this at least this set of poems is,
telling I guess, or uncovering a voice
or a narrative that sort of has been
sophisticated in some
way or has disappeared.
And I guess there's an attempted recovery
in some of these poems, I think.
And as Sonia mentioned this
idea about trauma, right?
Maybe there's some things
that should be left unsaid.
I think if a lot of the
things that we think
have occurred in the past,
have been maybe sugar coated
or dressed up in a certain way
and I think it's important
to sort of, I guess even if,
I guess it's worth the trauma or the,
the effort of uncovering
some of these stories
that have been sort of
buried or forgotten.
And so I don't think that I was...
I was cognizant of that, right?
Of not doing too much
or trying to do too much in these poems.
And so I dunno if you've noticed,
but I don't typically write in form,
but a lot of these poems were in,
in different forms,
informal traditional forms.
For example, I use (indistinct) in there
because I think that's a way to sort of
channel some of these,
maybe some of this violence
into something that's more manageable
and that the mind can sort of deal with.
So I typically write in very free,
free verse and not in structured form.
And so I think one of the
techniques that I used for,
for these poems was to use form.
But yeah, I don't know if what I said just
makes any sense, but yeah.
- To be honest, I don't
remember what the question was.
- Doesn't really matter.
- The conversation is
just so full and I'm just,
just processing.
So you would have to remind
me of what the question was.
- Why don't you say
more about your sense of
being a storyteller and maybe
there's something to say,
playing off what Rodney was talking about,
about what's revealed and what isn't,
or how to think about trauma,
how you think about
trauma in your own work
and what should remain unsaid,
if anything, any of that?
- Yeah, I don't know if there's anything
that should remain unsaid.
I'm just taking it back to Trisha's work.
That's the reason why maybe,
maybe that's the reason why
this book struck me so deeply
because so many of those stories,
were those that kind of aligned with
things that I had heard.
These are the things that
you don't say out like that
that's the stuff that I'm
interested in was hidden,
was kept like, the stuff, the China that,
that you don't let the
company, you know what I mean?
Like this side, that
other side of the bed,
like what's hidden under the bed,
what's trapped in the closet,
like that's the stuff that,
that I'm interested in.
It's not easy.
It actually from this,
I don't know if I'm
answering your question,
but I wanted to,
I was thinking about
something that Sonia said,
because maybe this all of it relates,
but and even thinking
about trauma I'm wondering,
she said like headache,
heartache, I'm wondering,
how do you even when you're
looking at for example,
like what's underneath, what's hidden,
what's kept away, like what
we sort of reject, right?
What we look down upon, what we shun,
what's consistently disregarded,
which is pretty much the case
of people like me, my people.
You know women like the woman in my story,
who was my great grandmother,
who was a maid, right?
Doing domestic work,
not able to use the bathroom in the house,
but you know, some of them
were good enough to breastfeed
you know, someone's
child, for example, right?
So I'm saying, how do we now for me,
I'm always thinking about
how do I tell this story?
How do I let this story lay
into me without being harmed?
And I wonder then for us as storytellers,
'cause it's so much to hold
and so much space to carve.
It's like, what do we do for ourselves?
What kind of self care?
How do you, so it's like,
I don't know if I'm even
answering the question,
but I think actually my question
is actually more important
than my answer, which is,
and I wanted to just
direct it at you, Sonia,
because I was literally blown away like,
well, I don't even know
how I'm sitting here,
like on this chair here and now.
I'm blown away by some of by your work.
And it was hard for me to
hear and to see, right?
I feel like obviously
particularly tied to a history,
her history and so I
wonder for you, how do you,
what kind of, self care,
like how do you sort of not lose it?
'Cause I know for me, like
just writing that story
or just reading this book is hard.
You know what I mean?
To like pull, pull myself out of it,
interface with reality
as a sane human being,
you know what I mean?
So this is kind of directed at everyone.
You know whoever wants to enter.
- I'm happy, I'm happy to take that,
just to respond quickly.
I feel so there to be very practical,
like so really helpful is to have a studio
so that you have a distance between
what you are doing and
what you are making.
And currently I don't have that.
So I'm literally living with my work.
It makes the work more
personal, but it's very hard.
I work collectively in
spaces that are overwhelming,
for example, to enter the
Royal Geographic Society
headquarters in London, in the map room,
where all those map makers left,
I started a collective
called it the map collective
because I knew it was just too
much for me to do on my own.
So working collectively
is a strategy for me.
I'm also a member of a collective called
What the Hell She doin?
And we're women from across the...
Black women from across,
all visual artists from across the
African continent and its DSPOs.
And what we have in
common is that people say,
what the hell is she doing?
So that's the support network that I have.
And the other thing is salt
bath, lots of bath and salt,
especially after going into places with,
or dealing or handling
these kind of bodies
that I feel and handling,
after handling that or
going into these spaces.
Some of the spaces that
Rodney was talking about,
how they're resident like
even like the paneling,
like salt bath afterwards.
So those are the practical
ways that I navigate this,
but very helpful also is to able to stop,
which can't always happen,
but that's also very helpful.
But I mean, of course this a
fellowship like this is just,
an amazing catalyst and enabling
so many other kind of things.
Those are my strategies, really.
- Yeah, just to echo
some of what Sonia said,
for me, I work or try to work
with other poets and writers
and try to promote them
as much as possible.
So I work closely with FlowerSong Press,
which is a small indie
press in South Texas
that puts out a lot of
voices from people of color.
We publish a lot of poetry and fiction.
And so trying to find new
voices to put on to the world,
I think is important to help others,
get their voice out out there.
I do pretty much the same
kind of work with Newfound,
which is a press that has
a little bit different aim,
but is also interested
in promoting voices of color primarily.
And then, well, I have a full-time job.
And so that sort of keeps me
grounded in the world I guess,
and not get carried into
what sometimes can be very
depressing work in the research.
'Cause it is very depressing.
I mean, it's, there's no way around that.
It's just and knowing
that, we're sort of at the,
at the knife edge in our
society in a lot of ways.
And we could sort of quickly devolve into,
into that state of exception
that sort of existed in the past,
if we aren't already
there in a lot of ways.
But yeah, in my work it's at a university
and so I'm helping students,
a lot of them first
generation students who,
are sort of navigating, the
university and college life
and just trying to make it in the world
and trying to figure themselves out.
So I think that's good 'cause I sort of,
I'm putting my energy into that primarily,
full time and then the poetry sort of
is something else that I do.
So I think it's important
to be grounded in something
where I'm helping somebody
else get along in the world.
- akua, would you like to talk
about the question yourself
that you raised for a second?
- You know, it's a
struggle in all honesty.
I mean there are times in
which, songs that I've written,
'cause I have to do a lot of research.
You know what I mean for
me to write, for example,
that song that I read
or performed a reciter
or what have you,
I had to do a lot of research
'cause I wanna be accurate
in the telling of this account, right?
And it's also like talking
to people in the family,
like there's so much
to learn in the kitchen
and conversations with
other women in the family,
it passed down even at a funeral,
you find out all these
other new information
you didn't know about something
that changes everything.
So I don't I guess it
depends on what it is.
I mean there are times in
which I've written things
and I couldn't get outta bed for days.
It was that heavy, it was
that hard but community,
and it was just kind
of like basically what,
what I heard is I think that
there's so much power and community and,
and being held by folks who understand
where there isn't much to be explained,
'cause it's so exhausting,
but just being held by
those who understand
has really helped me, you know.
- Thank you.
One of the other things on my mind
as all of you were talking was
the question of being
readers and researchers,
which I think I heard in different ways
each of you talk about,
and I just, I don't...
I could ask a very specific
question about this,
but I'd rather just raise this
as something for discussion.
I mean, Sonia you talked
about funnel and for example,
akua you were just talking
about the research,
Rodney you for example, were
talking about La Matanza
and your relationship to
that period or set of events,
which of course you would
know about through reading
maybe in other ways but
certainly through reading.
So I guess I just wanted to
raise this for discussion.
If there's anything to say about it,
how you think about yourself
as readers, as researchers,
why and what you read.
If you want to talk about
that when you stop reading,
if you don't, if you do
anything along these lines,
but it came up, I think in
all three of your comments.
Sonia, do you wanna start?
you can also take this in
a very different direction
if you'd like.
- I'm happy to start.
And I'm really glad that
you raised us because
when at one point someone said to me,
"Oh, artists don't read."
And I found that so offensive.
I have a very heavily
research based practice
and that is a lot of, a lot of texts.
I last time I had to read,
I had 23 boxes of books
with a as...
But books are not the
only relevant researchers
as Akua was saying like
funerals, the kitchen,
those places are deep places of learning,
very humbling spaces of learning.
And so for me, my research
based practice is, I mean,
I'm mining that,
but I'm also thinking
in terms of art history,
visual history, the
visual language of Europe
and the visual language of
the continent of Africa,
some of the things that thread through
what is carried through to the Caribbean.
And then I'm also thinking in terms of
states and here in Europe.
So all of those spaces are research.
Some embodied research, like
actually going to a foundation
or actually being in a great
house in the Caribbean.
Like my research,
I feel like my research
practice started when I was 12
and I was taken to Barrett house,
which is one of the great
circle, great houses
around the former plantations in Jamaica.
And I was taken there
because I was considered
to be too uppity.
And it was time to show
me where it came from.
And so I was standing
at age 12 in this house,
and that was the beginning of like
dealing with great houses.
And I feel like that that kind
of research embodied research
as well as like book
based re research is like,
just like, if you're doing
both, it's really tough.
It's hard work but very meaningful.
So and I can explain my work
voice in terms of research.
And I have to, because it's a
very hostile space out there.
I mean, when I wrote,
when I wrote about the Hogarth for Tete,
I had a really bad pushback.
This is not a...
How can you say this is a woman?
Has it come to, this was the cry,
like even the furniture is implicated.
So you have to base everything I say,
like on prestigious research,
because it's actually
attacking the material culture
and people don't like that.
If you are going to say,
"oh, this person is bad,
they were a slave owner."
That's not so bad because that's separate.
But if you attack the material culture,
we're all implicated.
Or if you are questioning
the material copy,
we're all implicated and
that's really problematic.
And of all the comments, like
many people were invited to,
to reconfigure Hogarth,
but mine was singled out
from for considerable more attack
simply because I was doing that.
Yeah, so it's necessary if you are doing
something that's challenging,
I kind of stayed quoted to,
to be prestigious researcher.
And I really thank my
first degree for that
because I was never able
to say anything remotely
work without backing anything up massively
in those spaces, so, yeah.
- I'll just jump and
say, I became a writer.
I think of myself as a lyrical,
like a romantic lyricist
within the hip hop tradition.
I became a writer through reading,
through being a reader first and foremost.
I mean, as a little girl,
I read Phillis Wheatley
Langston Hughes, Maya
Angelo, like, I mean,
just all of the greats, right?
Until I started to ask questions,
I still read Phillis
Wheatley and Langston Hughes,
but at some point you kind
of become radicalized.
And then I was looking for some,
some thin to sharpen my sword,
to sharpen my oyster knife
and started reading like
Zora and or Audrey Lord.
And of course the brilliant
genius Bell Hooks.
And then I discovered this
beautiful pool of black feminist
literature to which I'm still drowning in.
I don't want to come up to the surface.
Don't ask me to come out, I'm here.
Okay, y'all talking to me at
the bottom at the ocean floor.
But when I discovered Toni
Morrison is when my life just
Toni Morrison gave me
a standard and you know
Like Katia a window to see
if the window jumps through,
if you know what I mean,
like a world, but also, like you said,
reading, writing, speaking, listening,
and I think like listening, right?
Like seeing recording,
looking at what's happening.
Like that's in my opinion,
what's what makes one a good,
like, if we're talking about hip hop,
like a good emcee you know,
like you have to have kind
of like the poets are,
the profits, like, so you
have to kind of be open
to some extent you're reading
every anything to like,
make sense and then to produce,
our compass to construct a compass for,
So, yeah.
- Yeah, I've written
four poetry collections
and it wasn't until this last one,
this fourth one that I
really have a note section
where I reference things that
I've read and researched.
And I think it's important I guess if,
if we're writing as I am about
things that actually happened
historical occurrences, that,
if we want to be authentic
and we wanna speak truthfully,
I think it's important to,
to read at least those secondary sources
and become familiar with them.
Just if you want to be an ethical,
I guess, an ethical poet it's
necessary for you to do that.
Excuse me.
And yeah, so there was
something else I wanted to say
and I completely forgot.
Yeah. I don't what I was gonna say more.
- Well, I have a question for
you, Rodney, about reading.
Is there anything to say about
your background in philosophy
as a student of philosophy
and its relationship
to the work you do as an artist?
- Yeah, excuse me.
A lot of my work is actually informed by
looking at the world
philosophically, I guess.
And so, I guess in contemporary poetry,
maybe shying away from
abstraction is a common thing,
but I don't do that.
And especially dealing
with this kind of work.
And we mentioned before
that it sometimes gets a bit too heavy
and sort of removing
yourself through abstraction,
I think is one technique
that I think I use
and philosophy comes in handy there.
And also I think there's,
there's this sort of
classical clash between
philosophers and poets, right?
There're different ways
of approaching the world.
But I think philosophy is really
important in a lot of ways
and like the way even the,
like the poetry that I write at least is,
like couched I guess in the language,
because I don't...
I think if I wanted to do
something else I use fiction or,
or pros, or something like that,
as opposed to using poetry.
And so there's something that,
to be gained in poetry that I think that
sort of philosophies as
a technique illuminates,
and it's looking at Emily
Dickinson's famous line about
looking at the world sort of,
shoot, and I've forgotten the...
I've forgotten the quote,
but looking at it sort of a scan, right?
Not looking at it directly.
And so, I mean, I think that you,
if not overtly it's that
influences there in the background,
you probably heard it
working in the poems, right?
It sort of like to write elliptically,
especially dealing with the heavy,
heavy stuff in this collection.
And I seem to be,
I seem to be tiring out, sorry about that.
I'm forgetting my quotes.
- Well, we're almost at time I think.
Sonia, were you gonna add something?
Please.
- I was gonna add that,
I studied philosophy at St. Andrews,
I didn't fit Major in Philosophy,
but it was one of my minor
things that I studied,
obviously European philosophy.
And it struck me how often
they would talk of thinking
in terms of furniture, in
terms of tables and chairs
and that's really led me to think about
like that feeds into a lot of my work
with performing furniture,
this space of the philosopher
at the table and the chair
and all the labor that goes
into supporting the philosopher.
That's not that kind of happens
around that domestic space.
That's never questioned or theorized.
After graduation, I had the opportunity
to really study African philosophy,
pretty large, but philosophies
of different parts of Africa.
And that's really informed my work.
And some of it has come out
only I've discovered how much
is in the work by actively
seeking relationships with,
with other artists on the continent
who then start to explain
to me, this is what this is.
So it must be a kind of a blood memory
or some kind of other memory
that's, I'm calling on there.
And as akua was talking about listening.
I didn't talk about
this in my presentation.
I also have a whole thing about,
I talk about how I listen to furniture.
So I'm sitting and listening to the chair,
like, what does the chair want to do?
So for example, the
gentleman's club chair,
I spend many days listening to that chair
and said it wanted to rest itself.
So there's a deep philosophy
of listening to objects
that is very productive
a driver in my work.
And so sometimes I say
I performative practice,
we also have a listening,
a listening practice.
And yeah, I think that also comes back to
philosophy of what can speak
and what is allowed to speak
and what is considered dumb
that also undermines like a European,
Eurocentric philosophy,
whereas other philosophies
understand that everything has memory
and everything can speak.
- Brilliant.
- Yeah, akua I saw you nodding.
I wondered if you might wanted...
- Yes, she's giving me my
entire life, with her words,
Roberta Flack said, "Killing me Softly."
Yes, I find it similar in my own practice,
just listening to the character,
when the character now is able to speak
and you kind of just,
you have to like yield and allow yourself
to be a vessel for what comes.
And sometimes afterwards,
I might look back at something
I've created and it's like,
I wasn't even there, you know what I mean?
I don't know if like there
in some spaces there,
it is not really safe to talk in this way,
'cause people kind of
think that you're crazy,
you know what I mean?
But I do get what Sonia's saying,
because I do think that
there's an African philosophy
where that's just understood,
there's space for it
and like there's vocabulary
and like people understand,
that you're channeling
something and that's just,
and that's just like what it is.
Yeah.
- I appreciate that so much.
And I guess as a final
question and I just wanted to,
again, raise an issue more
than a specific question,
but see if it prompts you to,
to any remarks and that's
just something forward looking
that you've been thinking about
recently, you know, Rodney,
you mentioned the kind
of state of exception
and the knife edge that we seem to be on
or in, at the moment.
And there are so many
reasons to feel despondency
and paralysis in this moment.
And I know that the three of you are
certainly moving forward in many ways
and you're watching other people
move forward in many ways.
So just wanted to invite
you to say something
along those lines,
whether it's about something
you're excited about doing
that you haven't already talked about here
or something you see
other people doing that's,
giving you life and joy or something
along those lines right now.
It could be a nice way to close if people
wanna speak in that spirit.
I mean, there is a kind of
philosophy behind the question,
which is one that we need one another
and that we need to be
mindful of the good things
happening in the world and
take strength in those things.
And so like, anyway, I would
just invite any comments
or thoughts that you might
have in that spirit, Rodney.
- Yeah, I'm really excited about,
I worked with youth poets
as poet laureate in McAllen.
And one of the things that we did was
we published an anthology of youth poets
from the Rio Grande Valley in Texas.
And so I'm really excited
about like these younger poets
that are coming up and the
wonderful, wonderful work
that they're putting together.
I think they really have a strong voice,
I think a lot of them are
really mindful of history
and really trying to,
they have these social justice concerns,
I think that are important.
And so, they're not only
doing that like on the page,
but also out in the world and
they're heavily involved in,
that's just so hopeful to me because
I grew up in a time where
poetry was heavily controlled
by a certain type of person, right?
And so I wasn't welcomed, I
don't think into that world.
And now there's so much going on
where poetry is very accepting of,
people from different walks
of life and people of color.
And these younger poets I think,
are really embracing that.
And so that fills me with hope to see
where the poetry world at least that,
I know and love is heading
and it's really growing
and becoming more accepting, so...
- I'll say that I recently
became a mother and
it's a masterclass,
there's so much that I've learned
that I may have thought of intellectually,
but like now that it's embodied
and I'm in the fullness,
it's a masterclass I've learned a lot.
Like just stretched and
to expand and to widen
and the depth of my
heart, what it means to,
to love someone and also to be,
to be up close to see something so pure
and that kind of innocence
and excitement so closely,
that's so beautiful and kind of helps me
have hope for what's to come.
And it's also...
I mean, it's also left me very terrified,
like in all honesty,
I've never been more terrified in my life.
Like I have a little black
boy here, this is a miracle.
Like, there's a level of terror
that has to send it upon me,
but I'm not trying to get into that.
And I wasn't the question,
but just to now think of a new vocabulary,
how to explain the complexity
of the world to a child,
who's seeing things for the
first time, "Oh, look mango."
To experience that, the
taste of something sweet
for the first time, this
is really, really nice
and it's definitely glorious.
- Hopeful things.
So in terms of art, I mean today,
the Venice Spring opened and Simon Le
and Sonia voice respectively
are to women of color
opening national pavilions,
very exciting, 'cause
she followed their work.
I think that's really
interesting and hopeful.
In terms of the most
pressing issues of our time,
which I think are Social injustice,
which is rooted in slavery,
racism, and the environment,
which I think I've keep trying to say,
I think it's just one, this one body,
this one thing I think that
there's really interesting work
in terms of reparations not
just in terms of finances,
but reparations in terms of
environmental reparations
and putting land back to what it was.
I think that's really, really exciting.
There are a number of groups
that are working on that
and that's for me like
also a hopeful space.
- Well, thank you so
much all three of you.
I mean, I'm just,
it's hard not to sound very cliche here,
but you know, really
appreciate what you've given me
in this conversation.
And you know, I feel like
just being witness to your commitment,
to how thoughtful, how
hardworking you are,
how insightful you are, how
collaborative you are in your,
in your many spheres of collaboration,
certainly bolsters me.
I mean, I think there's many reasons to
be upset and be worried
and we would be wrong
not to be upset and
not to be very worried,
but I think the leadership
and the vision that,
that three of you and
others whom you know,
and are working with provide
is just, it's important to me.
So thank you all, all three of you.
Really, again, I'll just reiterate how
honored we've been to have
an association with you
and how grateful we are to you.
How closely we'll be keeping
track of you in the good ways,
not in the surveillance
place, in the good ways,
in the years to come
and how eager we are to,
to continue to support your work.
So thank you to the three of you,
thank you to our hidden staff.
And thank you to those
of you here on the call,
who are with us today and we wish you,
all good things and the
weeks and months ahead and,
and are grateful again for your time.
And Sonia, I know you're in a
very different time zone than ours.
So it's another time of
day or night where you are
than it is for the rest of us.
So thank you all and be well,
and we'll look forward to
staying in touch in the future.